[Music]  if you weren't satisfied with last  year's Batman V Superman because it  sucked you'll be able to pit the two  heroes against each other this May I'm  Matt and it's a bird it's a plane  nope it's just your GameSpot news update  injustice 2 is set to release for ps4  and Xbox one on May 16th but don't take  my word for it today Ed Boon posted an  image of the date to his Twitter account  we checked in with Warner Brothers PR  and confirmed that it's official  the last characters revealed for  injustice 2 were Harley Quinn and  Deadshot back in August  Harley returns from the original game  while Deadshot set to make his fighting  game debut it's worth noting however  that he does share some similarities  with Deathstroke from gods among us  we'll keep you updated as new characters  are announced so for that and much more  from the world of video games stay tuned  to gain spot